are you excited for the call of duty
Cinematic Universe well we've learned a
bit more about what those movies will be
about and I'm going to run you through
all of the details I'm Matt and this
gamespot news update is going Hollywood
Activision Blizzard Studios co-president
stacey sher said that the company has
plotted out many years of its movie plan
she noted that there would be a movie
that feels more like black ops while a
series based on modern warfare would
also be explored on top of that she said
that there could be a film that's more
of a hybrid of the two games now there's
a lot more to be discovered about the
Cinematic Universe so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to be one of the first to
hear all about it according to the
Guardian the first call of duty movie
could hit theaters as soon as next year
but it's not exactly clear how many
movies the franchise will consist of and
apparently Activision's film studio is
also considering a TV series based on
historical conflicts like the war in
Vietnam and World War 2 the video game
series has visited both of these errors
in past games and this year's entry is
even rumored to return the franchise to
the Second World War will report back
when mores announced but if you just
want some sweet headshots and firefights
check out our video on sniper ghost
warrior 3 in which we take on an outpost
and rescue some hostages
[Music]
you